professor I remember a moment where you
said CNN wouldn't put you on because
they disagree with you now by the way
for the record you've even attacked me
on my own show and I just don't invite
you back on well look Fox has always had
a much more diverse approach I've argued
with Tucker Carlson I've argued with
Laura Ingram nobody has ever told me
what to say on this show or any other
show luck if they I stand up yeah sure
look I stand up for civil liberties no
matter who the president is if if
Hillary Clinton had been elected
president oh and they were trying to
impeach her I would have written a book
called a case against impeaching Hillary
Clinton Congress cannot impeach
President Trump because if they did they
would be putting themselves above the
law the Constitution provides criteria
for impeachment treason bribery high
crimes and misdemeanors unless there is
compelling evidence of that impeachment
is not constitutionally permissible the
president isn't a best even Congress
this is not your your former civil
libertarian friends you have people like
Sean Hannity that you are more aligned
with on the issue of civil liberties or
spying look at call me bragging after
after his deputy said you don't need a
lawyer bragging well that they literally
set up something they wouldn't do in
other administration's of retired
33-year War veteran I'm sorry that's not
the America I love that's not the
constitutional republic
that protect civil liberties sir look I
agree and I want to make sure that every
American Conservative liberal centrist
right or left supports the Constitution
and supports civil liberties no matter
who the target is because today it's a
Republican tomorrow can be Democrat the
day after tomorrow it can be you so
preserve your constitutional rights in
civil area but you still let politics
interfere with civil liberties and
constitutional law you still have a
tough time with those subpoenaed 33,000
emails deleted bleach pit I said
something I'm happy to have an
investigation but I think the notion
yeah so you crazy me was wrong call me
let me go to jail on it
right alright we've done this photos
cake alright Joe from an immediate
standpoint they're begging Democrats do
this there's pressure they want it so
bad I don't care what happens the
Democrats nor are they aligned with the
American people Sean Quinnipiac just had
a poll out today one-third of Americans
support impeachment including just 35
percent of Independence that's the whole
ball game as we know but impeachment
think of it this way
remember the Cavanaugh hearings and what
that did from a ratings perspective
across the board it would be like a
steroid shot for these networks that are
struggling right now post smaller report
because they're not trusted and there's
fatigue around these sort of things and
again in terms of Rachel Maddow who you
mentioned earlier it's why people like
me objective people look at her
moderating a debate and saying wait a
minute that that can't happen because in
2016 she moderate a debate and actually
went up on stage on national television
and hugged Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton on stage pitcher shannon bream
or martha maccallum doing that to a
republican candidate the apocalypse
would look like nothing compared to what
the reaction would be forged neutron I
think me Rush and Levin can host the
debate we do a great job I think it
would be interesting to watch professors
who'd see like God know please help us
we need to get back to Walter Cronkite
type journalism where people can trust
what they hear in the media today you
know sir case yeah I'm proud of our work
on this show the last you should be a
half years because we've sought the
truth and the truth only and we were
right and these others were wrong